it's here my Apple credit cards we are
about to do an unboxing in case you
haven't seen one yet on the Internet
I was joking about unboxing my credit
card when they first originally
announced this and now here I am
actually unboxing a credit card
definitely something that I never
thought that it would be unboxing but
here we are we're doing it I already
signed up on the app and I have used it
for one transaction but this is the
actual titanium card laser-etched name a
beautiful matte white all-metal car just
what I never knew that I thought that I
wanted or needed would you take a look
at that this looks like a really great
gift card a gift card that you have to
pay back in classic Apple fashion
they've got this little cutout Apple
logo and when you open it up you are
greeted with your beautiful credit card
and this wonderful gradient pattern
which actually turns out to mean
something
so these gradients actually our
categories of things that you're
purchasing so the first thing that I
purchased was at a grocery store so my
card is like this color right now in the
Apple wallet in the actual Apple wallet
this is the orange and that is my one
purchase from Airwalk everyone is so
dangerous it's kind of like Whole Foods
or Target and you go in there and you
think you're gonna buy one thing and
then you end up buying the whole freakin
store this is the most exciting thing
activate your card wake your iPhone and
hold here you think I'd have a nice
downward shot of this but I don't so go
see somebody else's video this is not
gonna be as great let's activate my card
I'm gonna try to screen record this
they're not gonna work oh it has already
happened do you see that this works so
seamless with iOS it's basically like
you're pairing your air pods
I don't ever want to take it out of here
I mean I guess I can put it back in but
I don't really know the point is of that
come on get out be my friend
get in my wallet this looks really good
there's the credit card
there's my full name if you didn't know
I have a last name
shocking I know you've got our
laser-etched
name here leaves like chip reader for
chip reader cards and you've got Apple
logo and on the back you have the
Goldman Sachs and MasterCard logo and
then you have your little stripe here
for sliding this looks really good I
just feel like it's gonna get a little
bit dirty or scratched especially when
you're sliding it through different card
readers there is obviously more of an
advantage when you do use the Apple
wallet because you'll get 2% cash back
but if you use this you'll get 1% cash
back and you would 3% cash back when you
purchase things from the Apple store
which I definitely do quite frequently
let's do a drop test I get them to my
table
honestly I might even be able to fly
with this like this feels like it could
be well it anything can be a weapon to
be honest with you weapon let's go
through the app a little bit more if you
guys haven't seen this already this
definitely is something that is for
Apple users if you have an iPhone this
works so perfect with your phone and
what I love about it is because you
actually do get the information of where
you made your purchase and the app just
integrates so well with your phone
Apple card is ready to use get 2% daily
cash on every purchase cash is added to
your Apple cash one of the reasons that
it was a little bit apprehensive of
getting this it's just because I
honestly did not need another credit
card the way that I have things set up
right now it works very seamless with my
company and then my personal credit
cards but what I do like about this is I
feel like this is something that I'm
going to use for myself personally not
as Justine as in business the cash back
aspect is also kind of cool because
you've actually just get the cash right
into your cash wallet you actually get
the cash back the next day like it goes
right into your Apple cash wallet which
is pretty awesome a lot of times with a
lot of credit cards you have to
points and then you have to redeem them
you can redeem them for cash but then
they give you a better deal if you
redeem it for other things like flights
or hotels or things like that
I would it by any means say that I have
a credit card expert and you should not
probably be taking any advice for me on
what you should do in your financial
future but I think if this is something
that you are going to get it's something
that you should keep an eye on and try
to pay off every month because that's
something that I learned very early on
even in college I just kept very high
credit card balances I didn't pay any
attention to it at all
I was late on payments for a lot of
different things and that really does
affect you down the line when I went to
buy my first car and the first time that
I had to check my credit score they're
like we can't do anything to help
you're just you're a mess so for me what
I have done over the past I feel like 10
or so years is if I am going to buy
something on a credit card it's
something that I know that I can at
least afford to pay half of each month
and if I can't that's ok things
definitely happen so that's something
that is really cool here when you click
pay early this will show you your
current balance and it says my balance
is due September 30th this will show you
what your interest is if you don't
decide to pay all of it so now let's go
out to a store I'm gonna go shopping go
buy something it's over my first suit
I'm going to use
oh that's our needs it already did it
that was so fast my second soup I'm
going to purchase it on the action car
okay this is my first purchase
that'll show up four dollars and four
cents for my suit
actually you said cashback reduce the
credit card there it is
showed up again here's the recipe
well you can see the 1% for that one
where I use the actual card 2% for this
I would say my favorite thing about this
credit card is that there's no credit
card numbers on it at all if you
actually want to get your credit card
numbers you have to go into the app you
have to unlock it with face ID so you
can't believe do anything without your
face so even if I lose this credit card
there's no credit card numbers on it so
they can't just take this and start
shopping online using my credit card
number I can also go in and put a hold
of my credit card in case I did lose it
so everything is very easy and right at
your fingertips which obviously is very
classic of Apple well thank you guys so
much for watching every guy's enjoyed
this video there's gonna be so much more
apple fun coming up because the new
iPhone is gonna be out soon I'd imagine
they're probably gonna release a new
Apple watch the Mac Pro was gonna be out
so much stuff is happening and of course
as always I'll be bringing guys for the
ride I'll see you guys soon don't forget
to like this video and be sure to
subscribe and hit the bell so you'll be
notified when I post new videos I'll see
you later
[Music]